all right joining us now Stephen Miller
former senior advisor to president Trump
and founder of America First Legal ed
Ned Ryan American majority CEO Stephen
um
this economy and the numbers of for Joe
Biden we're going to get into those
later on but
the Border situation tonight as we're
seeing it develop
we're supposed to believe that Biden's
getting tough because some people are
going to be returned to Mexico in a
policy akin to what Donald Trump did
that's what the New York Times has
written tonight what's the real truth
that's absolute nonsense and I talk to
the people on the ground all the time
and I talked to the Border agents and I
talked to the ice officers and the
representatives and they know this is
the exact same line we've heard now for
two years they say oh no this time we're
really going to enforce the law this
time we're really going to do it it's
going to be the same thing we've seen
But times orders of magnitude they're
going to be releasing individuals by the
millions over the next two years into
this country we've seen 10 000
apprehensions nearly in recent days
on average and we've seen over 20 000
godaways in the last week that averages
if you include the unknown godaways over
500 000 a month that's the population of
San Antonio every three months Laura
this is the mass resettlement of illegal
aliens with an increasing number of
single adult men unvetted and unknown
being released into the country well
today the White House made this claim
ahead of title 42 expiring watch this
we are confident that with the tools
that we have in front of us that we are
doing everything that we can we have a
robust multi-agency plan to humanely
manage the Border through enforcement
deterrence and diplomacy again Congress
has failed to act
Ned Congress has failed to act as we see
a crisis an enduring crisis now for the
last two years at our border about to
get exponentially worse
yeah it's a useful crisis that the left
is intentionally created to transform
this country Laura and I think we need
to be open and honest about that the
left has hated this constitutional
republic they've been at war with it
since the beginning of the 20th century
they've been trying to deconstruct it
they've also been at war with the
American people the middle class that
has made this country great and one of
the ways that you wage war against the
Republic and against the middle class is
rapid Mass immigration in which you try
to drown out these people by importing
new ones I mean it's it's war against
the American people Laura there's no
other way to put it it's economic War if
you think it's bad now wait till we get
millions more into this country in which
we'll have to have Draconian taxes to
fund the social welfare welfare systems
to keep them from imploding it's war
against our institutions it's war
against our election system it's war
against our social and Civic fabric but
even more so Laura it's just war against
our Democratic Republic if you do not
have an enforceable border you do not
have sovereignty if you don't have
sovereignty sovereignty you don't have a
country and if you don't have a country
you don't have citizenship you're just a
citizen of the global global order ruled
by the world economic Forum that's where
the left is headed that's what they
intend to do this is all intentional and
and the thing that's amazing and
loathsome about the corporate
propagandists with CNN and MSNBC when
you point these things out they say
you're racist they say you're a white
supremacist no we're pointing out what
you're doing with rapid Mass immigration
we know what you're trying to do what we
supposed to call it when millions and
millions of people no country has
allowed this in the history of humankind
I don't believe Stephen have they
allowed anything like what we're seeing
unfolding tonight across our Southern
border has that ever been done before no
this is a very important point that
people need to internalize this isn't
just the worst immigration crisis in
modern history this isn't just the worst
immigration crisis in American history
this is the worst immigration crisis in
world history no country that has ever
existed that has ever lived that has
ever been on this Earth has allowed this
number of foreign Nationals to illegally
enter its territory we are living in
uncharted waters millions of people as I
mentioned over half a million a month
now are going to be recycled into our
country the populations of whole states
who's paying for them you're paying for
it I'm paying for the taxpayers are
paying Ned really quickly tonight Elon
Musk tweeted out a comment about how we
need more immigration into the United
States more legal immigration anyone who
wants to work hard should be able to
come here what's the problem with that
analysis given that probably most of the
world wants to come here still even
though our economy is struggling
well I'd have to disagree with Elon on
this point until we actually fix our
immigration system secure our border I'd
actually call for a moratorium on all
immigration until we actually get the
system fixed and then we actually go to
a merit system Lord to decide who will
come into this country and be a
beneficial citizen or a green card to
this country I'm not for it until we
actually figure out how to fix this
system and once we do that here then we
can have that conversation we don't even
know who's here it's not like wages are
going up to match inflation so everyone
always wants to keep wages down Steve
you've been so great about this over the
years flood the country with more
immigrants we don't know who's here
already what does that do to wages this
keeps war on the middle class is a war
on the working class it's a war on
unemployed Americans it's a warn
everybody who's striving for a higher
wage a promotion a better standard of
living if Republicans step forward and
talk the way you've talked about it
Laura for your whole career and said
this is an attack on working people to
pad the bottom lines of Corporations
they will win a congressional Landslide
talk that way think that way be clear
and convicted and say Joe Biden's the
party of Wall Street globalists and
those who hate the middle class yeah big
big corporations not small business
Stephen and Ned great to see you both
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else